the next front
in the culture war against education
is florida's new battle against math
textbooks david what the hell are you
talking about
has florida gone crazy yeah
yeah but that's not new
um the new situation in florida is that
the florida department of education
announced going into the weekend
that they are now rejecting more than 50
math textbooks not history that they
don't like how it's being taught
not human geography or social studies
they're rejecting more than 50 math
textbooks citing references to critical
race theory among reasons for rejecting
these books the department has rejected
54 out of 132 textbook submissions
because they don't adhere to the new
standards in florida or because they
contain so-called prohibited topics
this is
um
the the reasons they are saying are the
books have critical race theory in them
they include common core
they include unsolicited editions of
social emotional learning in mathematics
now asked for examples i've been unable
to find even a single one and this is
the new fight they're saying math is
being taught with a basis in marxism
they're saying math is attempted to be
taught with a basis in critical race
theory
and you may remember that florida
banned
these words
even though the language being used is
so stupid florida banned the teaching of
critical race theory in schools in june
now of course critical race theory
wasn't being taught in schools but what
they will say when pressed and they're
going to say the same thing with the
math books you say well but where was
critical race theory a subject
they'll say no no david it's much more
pernicious than that i go right into my
alex jones voice it's much more
pernicious than that
it's that they use critical race theory
as a framework to teach history it's not
that it's a subject and similarly uh
they're they're using it to teach math i
you know i remember when i was in school
you always had these funny math examples
calvin butterball
eats six apples
you remember these i don't know what the
critical race theory version is
juan has four oranges
is juan a dangerous illegal i mean like
i don't even understand what what is it
that they want to see in these books and
of course they're offended
they're outraged
this can't be this is terrible for our
children
and when we say well can you give an
example of the critical race theory in
the math books they don't they don't say
and conveniently and i don't want to
pretend that this is just about money
but textbooks are a big big industry it
just so happens that when you look at
the white listed textbooks
um
there's a bunch of
some of them are actually florida
textbooks
that
i i don't i don't we want to look into
it more but there's always potentially
some kind of cronyistic hey we'll make
sure that your textbook is the one that
gets purchased here
um this is the new fight
and what really pains me about this is
that this works look at virginia
look at the virginia gubernatorial
election that we had where glenn younkin
ran on banning critical race theory from
virginia schools and it convinced people
and many people voted for him for that
reason there's no critical race theory
being taught in virginia there wasn't
any way
now sure
youngkin's opponent terry mcauliffe made
some mistakes
like you know running against trump when
trump wasn't a candidate and young
didn't endure didn't embrace trump that
was a big mistake from democrats but
when you interviewed voters they said oh
yeah no i'm concerned about what's going
on in education critical race theory
[Music]
they fell for it
and they voted for yunkan so this stuff
works
and with desantis up for re-election as
governor in 2022 this year
and with desantis the number one
challenger to donald trump in polling
for the 2024 republican nomination there
is no doubt that he knows this stuff
works and they're going to keep pushing
it let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at deepakman also
tomorrow tomorrow it's already it's
already almost come and gone the next
david pakman show viewer town hall is
tomorrow tuesday april 19th
at 6 p.m eastern it'll be streaming live
on the pacman live youtube channel i
hope to see you there
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast 2 blinkist takes long
episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to in 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below